اذا هجوم واسع تعرضت له مقاطع فجر هذا
اليوم تواجد الان في محيط احد اكبر
المراكز التجاريه في قلب المدينه وهو قد
تعرض للاستهداف فجرا هذا المركز حتى يوم
امس كان يغذي العديد من سكان المدينه كما
تشاهدون باتا اطلالا بات ركاما بات انقادا
شظايا صاروخ الذي سقط عليه في كل مكان في
هذا الموقع الذي نتواجد في عمده المقاطعه
تحدث عن انفجارات كبيره هزت عمق المقاطعه
وفي الحقيقه نحن استمعنا فجرا الى اصوات
انفجارات ضخمه والدفاعات الجويه تم
تفعيلها على طول المقاطعه
والاداره العسكريه هنا في ميكولايف
الجنوبيه تحدثت في الحقيقه عن اكثر من
استهداف للبنيه التحتيه لشبكات المال
لشبكات الكهرباء بالاضافه الى منازل
السكان والحديث ايضا عن بنى صناعيه ايضا
تعرضت لل الاستهداف والحديث ايضا يتواصل
عن استهداف المناطق الساحليه في ميكولاي
بالحديث عن اوتشاكوف كوستروب وتقول
السلطات بان القصف على ميكولايف وعلى
العديد من المقاطعات المجاوره الجنوبيه
لاسيما خرسون باتا يتكثف باتا يشتد يوما
بعد يوم وفي ضوء كل ذلك تشتد المواجهه
والقصف والقصف المتبادل بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه على طول خط التماس في
الجنوب الاوكراني تامر صمادي الجزيره